It's you versus Sean and like
Yeah, exactly right just take the L like 50% of the time I did thank you
Okay, I'll do electric boogaloo all right cool well
All right, well we start from like yeah, let's start from zero just for context
We just recorded the intro to this and then Sean's fly was open the whole time. Oh
My gosh, yeah, what a mall you know, okay. All right. Let me let me really reintroduce the scenario. So
Okay
I'll say your this is Sean
Okay, do it do it. This is Sean. Yo, is that right? Yeah, so Sean works at AssetNote
AssetNote is an attack surface management tool ASM. Yeah
I'll let you introduce sort of the background and how it became a thing and and sort of what spurred it all and go
Just go ahead. Yeah, so ASM or attack surface management is like two big pieces one is reconnaissance
Which is understanding what your attack surface is
From our perspective that's mapping out what is publicly facing
So what can we see from the internet?
What DNA starter? Do you have what IP ranges? Do you have and then more nuance than that is things that you don't know you what you have?
So like what's running on the internet that we can attribute to you?
So it's like it might be random IP addresses that have TLS certs that point back to you
Right or like what we what we consider like cloud assets that you don't like don't typically fall under what you can typically classify
But we have our heuristics to figure out this still belongs to you and it's still important
So that's the discovery piece of understanding like what's there and then the part
I think we do really well at is the security piece
Which is now delivering value on top of what your attack surface is finding what bugs do you have?
Telling you that these bugs are still there and checking that continuously
So we will be sending not necessarily the seen amount of traffic, but we do a lot of validation for very high signal bugs
Yeah, and I think a lot of the value people find out of our platform
Is that when we send you an email saying we found something it means that one is is exploitable and two you need to fix it
Yeah, so you know, we ignore all the bullshit. We skip all the TLS findings the cypher suites
Like we only tell you that you know, you have it necessary from your attack surface
We found the exploit for it fix this or you have a like exploitable version of tableau running
We can validate the RCE. He is the like here's the payload and the response for it
Um a lot of the value comes from the high signal and the reliability
From how much coverage we get. Yeah, and and I guess just to add a little bit more context to that
Like we say Sean works for us, you know, but actually Sean built acid now
Yeah, yeah, Sean and chubs were were the yeah initial programmers of this this tool. Yeah
So the Genesis of it was very much like we wanted to capture all this amazing stuff that Shubs already was doing like he was doing this
Like bounties for the bug bounty space. Yeah
Oh, and he was he had this amazing pipeline where he was constantly discovering new assets on
Targets is getting notified on them and then automatically running his own tool set across these targets
Right, right, but then it's grown so much more than that
And I think in this process there's a lot of things that you think like oh, it's pretty easy to just translate from bug bounties
Oh my god, I do know
But you want so so much more about like it's a big difference from having something like oh, I need this to run
You know once a day or once a week or once a lot
or something to having this run
Every hour with an SLA and a customer being able to run queries against their data set that might be hundreds of gigabytes large
Oh my god whenever they want for how much of data they want and like getting getting from like, you know
bash scripts and python scripts right to reliable production code is
Did you did you know what you were getting yourself into here when you signed up for this like I signed up to write like tiny go program
Right, yeah
I remember I was in union. I'd get messages from Shubs being like I need you to help me write this thing
And I'm like, okay, sure. I'll write you a signature scan. I can't be that hard
I can't support it's like, oh, we just need to send some requests and I'm like, okay, that's easy enough
So like one signature scanner later we can send like you know 80,000 requests a second
Oh, right gosh, dude
But now you have a different problem. It's like, well, how do we run this?
And it's like we can't just have this DDoSing people constantly, right?
I mean, it's not even DDoSing. It's just one box
It's just one box sending a bunch of
So there's there's a whole bunch of like architectural learning we had where we've just like as we sort of grown
We've realized that you know, we went through the phase of let's just run everything on one instance to okay
Now we need to start like splitting up our services
Not everything will scale the same way, right?
And it's like, okay, so we support all that
Let me pause you there for saying because that that's kind of where we want to go with that, right?
It's like where I was kind of thinking we could we could go with this episode is kind of pick your brain for the bug bounty hunters out there like
What kind of architectural decisions would you recommend?
Having having sorted all of this
You know for the past five years of your life have it having lived that you know building this to scale having lived
Going from the bug bounty phase to the full-fledged enterprise software grade, you know
Um, where would you start? Where what would you do? What design to take decisions would you make?
I know that that's a really big question, but we can start with this. We were talking about message brokers earlier today
Yeah, can you talk a little bit about message brokers? What kind of role they play in this architecture?
Yeah, and why you suggest what you suggest
So, okay, I guess the first question is like what is a message broker? And why do people use them? Right?
Yeah, it's like there's kind of two ways of doing things
When you're trying to automate things or build a large system. Yeah, the first thing is you can do things synchronously
So it's like I want you to you know, give me all the subdomains and scan them
So you'll just like run a script that gets all the subdomains and then run a script that scans all right
That's okay. Yeah sequentially that's okay when you have like one set of things to do
But when you want to be like I want to see this every hour on the hour and
Have like hundreds of thousands of millions of hosts to do
You're gonna have very very long running scripts
And you're probably like you know for a hundred thousand or a thousand hosts
You can probably run it in one script and get it done in an hour
Yeah, but when you enter the phase of like millions tens of millions hundreds of millions of hosts
Which does happen in bug bounty and we we've I've run scripts that were that were against three million hosts
Yeah
In the bug bounty programs that I have access to yeah
And like you might have heard of things like axiom they'll help you paralyze these things. Yeah, that's fine
But at the end of the day, you're still like you run them and then you collect them and then that's kind of it
Yeah
When you move to the realm of like I want to start having things like pipelines
Um, then you will start venturing to the world of things like rabbitmq
Right or like amazon sqs or all of these different like queuing services and that's kind of what message brokers are
It's a way of queuing up a whole bunch of things
Uh with what we call producers and then you have a whole bunch of services or like programs that start taking things off this queue and consuming them hence consumers
Uh, and that's sort of the role the message broker feels
Okay, so the message broker is you have various pieces that you want to work
asynchronously, so you got let's say you've got your subdomain tool and every time it finds a subdomain
It like pushes a message out to the message broker and that message gets sent out to the other microservice that's going to do scanning
And it gets sent to another microservice that's going to do
You know, it's going to pull the tls cert and another one that's going to like pull the html pit, right?
Is that the that's the idea, right?
Yeah
Okay
So yeah, it's pretty much like
It's the glue
Yeah, it's kind of like the glue or the way you get messages around
Yeah, it's the mailman
You put a letter in the mail mailman decides, you know, well, it's not quite that but it's more generic than that
Yeah, yeah
It's pretty much the idea like you know, you chuck the mail in
Yeah, the principle of that, yes, you're sending a letter out and then many people will receive that same letter
That's where it varies
Joel, you know the rule, we don't do live analogies here on Critical Podcast
Just ignore that
Every time
Don't laugh, Mariah, my wife's over there laughing because I suck at analogies
No, every time I try to do an analogy live on the pod, it's terrible
But yeah, okay, so we've got these message brokers there
They're fanning out, you know, system or the messages to all the different pieces or
You know, I guess we were talking a little bit earlier today about event-driven
Um sort of architecture
Yeah
Which is not necessarily different from that but is
I guess more different at a conceptual level than a
Yeah, yeah
So event-driven architectures and pardon me if I'm wrong
But generally the idea is there's sort of two ways this organically grows out
One way is this and very much if you're doing your own thing you'll sort of fall into the first category as opposed to the latter
The first category is like, ah, I've got these things I want to do
So I want to get TLS certs, I want to do a port scam, I want to get a HTTP title, right?
So you have ideas of processes or programs you want to run
So then you sort of build out your queues
Um or whatever your like message broker partitions, however you want to call them based off these tasks
And you say like I'll have one queue for TLS certs, I'll have one queue for ports, one queue for titles
Um and the outcome of that is pretty much almost each service you think of will eventually have a queue by itself
Um, but I think the other way is event-driven architectures where you very much think about what kind of data am I working with?
Right, it's like I'm working with subdomains. I'm working with IP addresses
So you start flipping the model and thinking that when I discover an IP address
Then now I can start informing things like I want to start a TLS scammer
I want to start getting titles from it
And it's a very it's a slight nuance, right?
Because you're no longer thinking about it like what am I trying to do?
But it's so much more what do I have or what is already happening?
Yes, what is happening and then what do I want to do from those events that occur?
Okay, so an example of that, you know, and then we were talking about earlier today is like let's say we have a
Um, you know, I guess we could say SLA, but it's not really that in our big bounty context
Let's say we have a desire to have an updated picture of DNS on all of our assets every five minutes, right?
Yeah
You know when that five minute or maybe that four minute, 45 second, you know mark comes around
We can trigger an event that expires our current DNS representation
And that event can trigger various different activities. Is that how I'm understanding it?
Yeah, so I mean you could go one way of like saying when things expire usually will be things that happen
So you might say every every five minutes you will do a DNS resolution of all your assets, right?
And then oh that and that's an event. Yes, so the event would be like we've discovered this
This subdomain maps of this DNS record, okay, and that's the event, right?
And then now like part of that event the data you have is a subdomain and IP address, okay, right?
So how do you stop the
the
subscriber services from basically just becoming bottlenecks themselves because
You have like one thing doing one thing, but
It may need to do a lot of work
To do that, right? So like say you have one thing that's doing the DNS resolution another thing that's doing title getting the http titles and so on, right?
What DNS resolution might take significantly longer? Yeah, and so
One of those things may be bottlenecks just because it's going to take long. How do you get around that?
There's a couple ways. I mean one is you can go faster
I like a lot of time that we've spent
um, at least in the couple years i've worked is
You have start heavily optimizing for these things, right?
You realize that detecting technologies is taking like, you know, 30 seconds to a minute per website, right?
That's forever, right?
So you start optimize that aggressively. Can I get 60 seconds down to 30 to 20 to 10?
At some point you are bottlenecked by the technical limitations, right?
But once you get to that point, it's like okay now i'm already six times faster. That's heaps better
But then the other side is sort of what you're leading to is now scaling outwards, right?
You can start partitioning your work into smaller pieces instead of resolving all 300 million DNS records
You have at once you start shutting them up and say like each i'll have multiple workers starting to create events. Yeah, right
I'll start scaling these out
Parallelizing them and creating replicas
All axiom sh or whatever the website is for sure
Um, and then now you can have you know 300 workers each resolving a million at a time, right?
Um, and then as you sort of create all of these shots now you sort of get over these issues of throughput
Okay, yeah
The other side is you sort of can do architectural decisions with the tools
So instead of just having one
Big bulk result in one big bulk of data is you start streaming the results out
So it's more like it in the tool in itself is also asynchronous
Yeah, and then you have a continuous stream of things
But depending on the scale you kind of don't really need to make all these optimizations
Yeah, yeah, so I was actually just about to add that like
So this episode and I think the lessons that we're learning here from sean
This is him doing this at an enterprise grade scale
And for like we talked about
On the pod before like a lot of bug bounty stuff is literally just duct taped together with like crazy
Nucle-i scripts, so don't yeah, yeah, don't feel like you have to do this unless you want to unless it's your thing to like
Write cool. Hmm. Do you disagree with that? You're looking you're making a face?
I make the face because I think it's something because you do that shit. Is that why?
Oh, wait, yes, it is because I've lost to sean's recon scripts before
I mean speed
I'm an engineer because that's my day job. My job is to build this for the enterprise. I beat you in dns recon because I need to
For work. Yeah, but I think if you're if you're one person doing this by like I have a team of people supporting me
Right when I say like I build a service that shards it up runs asynchronously across a message broker
I have a team of two incredible like infrastructure engineers that maintain like I don't know 60 kubernetes clusters
Oh my gosh, yeah, I have a team of five engineers that helped me build software to do all of this mind you
I don't use asset note for bug bounties, right?
Right, right
Enterprise
This is an enterprise grid thing
But when I'm talking about these problems we're having they're very much similar to what you see in the bug bounty space
Yeah
And I think when people say that you can't scale beyond this or like this tool doesn't do this
I think that's a limitation of time and effort not a limitation of the tool
Yeah, I think you can solve technical problems of like
Oh, you can't scan this far so you don't have this data
Yeah, you just need to be able to invest the time and energy into it
Yeah, that's one of the things I really like about talking to you too is like like we
I feel like the question for me a lot of times is like all right
Well, you know this isn't moving fast enough, so I'm gonna scale outward and just but and then you see you
You know, you bring it refreshing perspective
But what if you tuned mass scan to actually just be able to go, you know six or seven times faster?
And then that just solves all your issues magically and and you know, it's not necessarily a different
It's even more intriguing to be able to dive deeper into those problems because in order to tune it
You have to understand it at a lower level
Yeah, yeah, which I think fosters a lot of growth as a hacker if you do that
It's a very very different skill set
Yeah, I think it's but I also think that's like a really good way to look at it because like if you think about it, right?
If you have like a really inefficient system instead of just multiplying that system to try and make it more efficient
Optimize the system and then see if you need to multiply it because you're gonna have cost savings
You're gonna have scaling savings like it. It's it's it mo like that
Lack of multiplication is gonna save you in so many other areas where instead of having to like
Use an inefficient system multiple times in a row to up to like compensate for the lack of optimization
You could just solve that by optimizing and spend a little more time doing that instead
And it feels so good to you know
Like when you get something optimized like I did this once right I
Rerote it like all of my other stuff is like garbage like it's Python taped together, you know Python 2.7 mind you taped together
But this one time I was like, you know what I
Don't know why I fixated on this problem so much, but I literally was like all right
You know what aquatone it takes a picture of the you know the website
And then it downloads the tls cert and I was like, you know what I want to do that in one tcp connection
Yeah, and and and because it was making two tcp connections
I was like for some reason that day. It was like killing me
So I like wrote this whole thing with chrome dev tools protocol to like grab the tls certificate from chrome dev tools protocol
And then also take the screenshot at the same time and it was not that much faster
And if it but I felt great
I was gonna say it should be like 2x right?
It's like you know, it wasn't even that I mean it was
I mean you'll find anything involved in chrome is this black box of time and effort
Oh, yeah, we've spent
months because we like the only way you really can do proper technology detection is you need to evaluate javascript
Right, yeah, and there's been all of these solutions that try to get around it
But at the end of today, you kind of need a run-up browser
Yeah
And we've spent countless hours trying to shoehorn existing solutions into an enterprise context
At some point we're just like
Fuck it. Yeah, just rewrite it. Yeah
Yeah, yeah
And do you ever draw that line where you're like this isn't worth the time and effort or or is the juice kind of always worth the squeeze?
Um, we always start with the simplest solution and almost everything that we've implemented will start with
What can we do that gets us 80% of the way there with 20% of the effort?
Like AssetNode started as python scripts around existing tools and then as we sort of grew
I'm on it
Yeah, that's the origin story of every automation platform
Yeah, yeah, anybody who automates does that
I think like if you're doing it yourself, that's 100% where you should start and you should not start from
An event-driven architecture or like an auto scaling kubernetes system
Yeah, you should start from janky python scripts that do
That automate what you're doing now. Okay, um into something quicker. Have you ever seen that xkcd about automation?
Oh, I love that test. Ah, okay. We'll put it up on the screen, but but basically there's this xkcd graph
What's the timestamp?
What is the timestamp? I'm gonna write that down so we don't forget
Okay, so yeah, so basically there's this xkcd graph, right?
It's like what people think automation is gonna do and it's like oh, you know
You do a little bit of automation slow you down a little bit and then you exponentially get faster
And in reality what happens is it gets a little bit faster and then you lose all of your productivity
Trying to maintain that tool and trying to make it better and like you spend so much more time fixing and working on the tool
Than you ever spent like actually getting the benefits from the automation
Yeah, and I think that's like perfectly exemplified by what you just said because it likes it's so easy to fall into that trap
Where you're like hmm, I really need to do this perfectly
I need to like build the best fastest way to do simple task a right and instead you should just being be like
There's this acronym kiss keep it simple stupid, right and just keep it simple just
80% of the work 80% of the result 20% of the effort, right?
It's just like so much easier to start from there and then
Re-evaluate and iterate on where you're at. Oh, and it's just like iterate iterate iterate iterate until you're hit you hit a wall
And then iterate again and then I think the best results i've gotten from all the automation stuff
Was not actually spending time planning out a whole architecture
Was just running it and every week sitting down like for one day that week and asking like why like has this been effective enough this week?
Um, and I think we had a period where we were competing on some takeovers, right? Yes, we did
It would go back and forth every other week of seeing like who is getting more takeovers or right whatever
Um, and the process literally was like every week. I'd ask myself
Has this week's yield been sufficient or do I need to spend time making it better right and
The weeks that I made the most progress in making it better
Is when I have the lowest yield because there's no better motivator for you to make something then knowing just is getting loaded
No, that's somebody else is making your money. Yeah
So how do you how do you evaluate like at an enterprise level when you're trying to optimize?
What are you doing to figure out where those pitfalls are within your application? How do you analyze that? Right?
And so so, you know, we've we've done our disclaimers now
We get the real real reason we have him here
Which is for you freaks that love to code love to optimize and want to be you know
When you're your bounty is in bug bounty by being the fastest and over optimizing
Voila here we go. So yeah, okay
It's a very different scale when you're operating across so to explain a bit like okay to not disclose our entire architecture
At a high level we scale out our services across hundreds of replicas across hundreds of ec2 instances
right and
Profiling and I guess observing the data there is very different from running something on one machine
So in our case of like me running my own stuff
I would just have one ec2 instances running this one program that does you know
Whatever takeovers they're doing right right right in that case is pretty straightforward
I can just attach a profiler use the inbuilt golang profiler and start looking at okay
Where's time being spent?
How am I using it? Etc. Right and just do some basic programmatic optimization. Okay, so
I'm gonna pause you there because I've never done that
So essentially what you say and of course you just attach the basic profiler
No, and I just I I so the profiler is something that tells you what operations are taking the longest in your code
execution
Yeah, so what a profiler does is that it records what's happening in your program
With a small amount of overhead in I think golang is probably in the wrong like five to ten percent at worst
I think now it's in the wrong one to two percent. That's that's great
So effectively what it does is it sort of takes a whole bunch of snapshots every every millisecond or every second
You'll take like a whole bunch of snapshots and ask like what is running at this moment?
And then what you do with this all these snapshots is you aggregate them together
And it tells you at this point in time this function is running and this function took seven seconds to run
Right, and you can start seeing a heat map and they have all of these great tools
I think there's a great like flame graph profiler that shows you exactly
How long is the spent in real action?
Wow, we're a given period of time
And the value of that is that you sort of start to very clearly see where time is spent in your program
Am I spending all that time waiting on a network request?
And if that's the case then maybe I can spend like more network more network requests at the same time waiting sure right
So you can start paralyzed horizontally and then you might start hitting a bottleneck of oh
I'm actually no longer spending all my time waiting on network requests
I'm spending all my time in these like three lines that is actually just looping over all the subdomains really really fast for no reason
Right, so maybe I can start skipping out of that loop or restructure it
So I don't need to loop over that so many times sure sure and you sort of slowly start to understand
Why my program is slow, right?
Yeah, wow, I love I love that
Actual data driven approach there like like for me
If I were to try to do that same thing, I would look at the code. I'd be like, okay
Where's it slow?
Just kind of guess you know
That's what they don't
That's their whole reason I think you see there's a lot of engineer like pure engineering companies
Is that like this is very common practice?
Yes, where it's just like you have a system that needs to run at scale just due to user demands
and
In order to make it work, you have to figure out what where it's being slow and make it better and optimize it just to simply function
whereas
It's almost like that but it's to like another level where it's like yeah, it needs to function
But also it needs to be like
The best, right? It needs to be better than the best
So how do you make it better than the best?
I mean, you know if you want to go the next step after that like at some point profiling just your program isn't enough
Right because like at some point you're gonna start when you start doing a whole bunch of networking stuff
You start asking questions like well, how do I interact with the network?
Right and like the obvious answer. Okay, you can make that work faster
Right, but this comes back to like that question of what happens when you type in google.com
How many layers deep do you want to go over? Yeah, dude, it's so funny you mentioned that because we literally talk about that all the time
You know, and it's it's literally like
That that comes having a core understanding of how that works. Yeah is just absolutely pivotal to everything
You know, it's you have to understand every single detail of that. Yeah, there's a great get over you go that goes over like
All the way different stuff goes all the way to like the key press and it's like it's like an electrical signal is fired
Oh my god, it's really good. We need that
Yeah, that's amazing. I've never heard of that. I'm gonna text you right now
Yeah, um back when I was in like university that was like all the all the interviewers
Yeah, that were like, you know, oh, they're gonna ask you what happens when you type google like google.com in a search bar
And so like, you know, that was something that you would just like memorize. Yeah, it does dns look up and then yeah
I feel so validated right now because like I never knew that anyone else like put as much importance on that
Like that's where I start with everything like and oh man, that's I
I mean don't get me wrong. You can go very far in the other direction of like over optimizing for this
Yeah, it kind of depends on what you find fun
Like sometimes I find fun and just doing all of this stuff other times like you know, you probably should be hacking instead of
Yeah, exactly
Yeah, but I can imagine that it like acid notes scale
Even the very very marginal optimizations are going to be super worth it
Because of the scale that you're operating on
So one of the current projects that one of my engineers is working on is
um
One of the features and that we have is
Integrating with like your cloud services so integrating with aws or integrating with gcp
um, and we've just on boarded a customer that for pulling assets in yes, so like we we ingest all that data
We help enrich it give you extra information and then that sort of feeds into the whole platform. Sure
Um, one of my engineers is currently working very closely with the customer because they've
Initially when we built this feature, we're like, okay, approximately what scale can we handle and a big question that sort of you mentioned earlier
Data-driven decision making right is like understanding what what performance properties are we looking for when we build this?
What are our expectations? What can we handle?
A customer came in and we're like, okay, we set a reasonably high number
It's like 10 times more than whatever and our customers are doing. Sure, sure, sure. They came in and onboarded with 10 times more than that
Oh, no
You're joking. There's no way
We spoke to them and they're like, yeah, it turns out aws had an internal limit and we had to ask aws to bump that
Oh my gosh, dude, you can't even rely on the aws limits
We estimated pretty good, right? Like we estimated to what aws's maximum public limit was
Sure, sure, sure, sure. They're above that by another order of magnitude. Wow, dude. So he's spent the past few weeks
optimizing our service for synchronizing this it
An inordinate amount like
Yeah, our average expectation is we should be in sync with you every five minutes. Yeah, right. It's such a that's a good that's a good expectation
Optimizing this 90% got us down to like 10 minutes, right? Wow
And when you already optimized at 90% to get another 50% on top of that huge
It is very time
Unbelievable amount of optimizing like yeah work to get there
And now you're looking at just like well, what is all the micro optimizations can we be doing? Can we be like
Not making requests for things that we don't need? Can we be turning off requests that we know are immediately going to fail?
Can we start pre-caching requests? Oh my gosh
We hit a second entire set of limits
We didn't realize existed on assuming role between aws accounts
All right recorder died. Yep jump back in. All right, so jumping back
I guess we need to get back on track anyway, so all right, so bringing this back to discussion surrounding if you were gonna
Oh
That's spicy
Final destination
What the heck
Did you think that was what that was?
All right
So
Yeah
The ghosts are not happy that we're revealing the optimization secrets right now
Oh my gosh
Okay, so Mike died. We're getting back to the topic here
Yeah, so just bringing it back around we want to try to bring it back to bug bounty and
and get some architectural wisdom on this
So we already talked a little bit about message brokers and the role that they play and using that in order to
build an architecture that allows all these different microservices which perform all the different tasks like performing scanning
and
you know DNS resolutions and you know volume scanning all that
Those those get sort of sent and connected by the message broker
What kind of message brokers would you recommend and what other pieces of the stack would you recommend that it would save us a headache
um that you've learned over your years of engineering sort of thing
It depends on how much time and money you have right?
I think
a lot of things you'll see is like SQS
RabbitMQ
Yeah
I think those are okay solutions if you need something now
Actually, I wouldn't recommend RabbitMQ
Yeah, just don't don't do RabbitMQ
The reason being it's very difficult to keep alive
And then once you start getting to a certain scale, there's an excellent blog post
I need to dig it up somewhere
I might link it to you
Yeah
Where it says don't use your message broker as a database
Right?
Yeah
And the idea being that if a message is sitting in your message broker for too long
Then now you actually are just using your message broker as a database instead
Right
Which you shouldn't be doing
The idea is that your message broker is where you queue things up and then those things get consumed
So eventually you should try to get to zero
So what do you use to sort those messages if when they're in the queue?
So we do use the queue
But the idea is that you should have enough processes to make sure your queue is being consumed
And if you're seeing that your queue is only going up
Or what I recommend is like for a message broker like NATS
Which I think is a great piece of software for this because it's relatively lightweight
It's got a whole bunch of different SDKs we'd implement against
And it's relatively
N-A-T-S
Yes, N-A-T-S
Okay
It's pretty good for this and there's a whole bunch of other projects adjacent to it that help it
For example things like Keda
K-E-D-A
Okay
So if you are using Kubernetes
This is a great way to scale it
So NATS is a great solution
You might also have like things like Redis
The only difficulty with Redis is that
It's very hard to get good visibility into it
Oh really?
Okay
So that's very important
If you're asking questions like how long has the message been there?
Or when should my messages be expiring?
Redis may not be the best solution because you need a whole bunch of other things to manage that for you
Redis is really good at what it does
Which is be a key value store and give you really accurate results really quickly
But for something that you actually want to use as a message broker
Things like NATS have a whole bunch more features
Saying things like I want to expire messages that are there for more than 24 hours
Yeah, that would be clutch
Because even if you do get a system clogged up
Right
Yes
You want to have some way of making sure it doesn't DOS the rest of your node
Exactly
Right
Like you need to have all of these
That's the problem I was having with RabbitMQ
Yes
Like it will run up all your storage and then ship my disks full of my systems dead
Or it will run up all the RAM
Yeah, goodbye all my messages
Goodbye everything else that's running
Yeah
So you do want to set yourself some limits
Understand that okay
I want the maximum capacity to be one gigabyte of memory
I want the maximum disk space to be 15 gigs
Sure
I want the maximum age of my messages to be 24 hours
And if things are taking more than that then I've got a problem with my code
Yeah
It's not a problem with the message broker
Right
So there's that piece to it
And one of the things that I learned from the message broker era was like
You know when I was working with it was
You really want to make sure that you're consuming at a faster rate than you're getting things published into
Right
Like you know you alluded to that earlier that you know it needs to hit zero
And even when you've got a bunch of data coming into your pipeline like as long as you're consuming
At a faster rate than you're adding to it
Yeah
It should be going down and that's what you want to see
I mean of course it can have spikes
Right
Because naturally some things will have more spiky and like what are they called seasonal trends than others
Sure sure sure
But yes you should be aiming towards at some point it should be able to hit zero
And if it never hits zero then now you have a question of why is it not hitting zero
Is something taking too long or I'm not scaling it out at night
And then we go back to optimization
Yeah
Okay
So we got Nats and Keta
Keta is great for scaling but it's mostly kubernetes relevant
Okay
And if you're running something yourself probably don't use kubernetes
Right
I have a team of people I mean at one point it was just me managing a lot of kubernetes
Yeah
I'm sure that was fun
Fun's one way to put it
Yeah I mean I did a kubernetes cluster for my microservices when I was doing this
This architecture and it was a lot of it was a lot of problems you know
And and I think you know one thing that we talked about earlier was like trying to run mass scan or any really performant
Scanning from within a container is just not going to happen right
There's there's a whole bunch of kernel training you need to do to make that work
Okay
So one of the most common problems you'll hit is you'll hit what they call a contract limit
And what a contract limit is is pretty much when you're making connections on your operating system
What your kernel needs to do is be able to track what packets going out and coming back
Actually belong to us right right like your kernel doesn't want when I send out a web request for google.com for
Joel to start sending me traffic and then intercept my google.com request and then poison that right
Sure sure sure in theory you know
Yeah, so what they do is they track all the ip ports combinations going in and out yeah, and things that are not relevant
They just drop right right and that's what they call a contract and there's a big table that tracks all of this
What a contract limit is is that this table can fill up and this is very
This is very like likely to happen with port scanning because what are you doing?
You're just spanning a bunch of you're spending a bunch of IP addresses and ports
Which are the two things that contract tables rely on right?
Right and when you're doing it across millions of hosts across tens of thousands of IP addresses
Your table is going to be full really really quickly
And is that contract table at a host level or a container level?
Cool
So depending on how the networking you have is set up
If you're using like kubernetes level normal container networking you'll have two different IP address spaces, right?
You have the pod IP address space and then you also have your nodes IP address or the instances IP address
Sure
And then now you need a translation layer of
When a web request goes from the port when a packet goes from the pod to the instance and then out to the internet
Now you need to translate that NAT back into the pod
And if you're not sure what i'm talking about network address translation allows you to have multiple IP addresses behind a big IP address
Right
It's how your router gives you an IP that is not connected to the public internet
Yes
And in kubernetes it's kind of the same thing
Your pods need to get an IP address that's not connected to the public IP address
So they have that translation as well
So this actually happens on the kernel of the instance
And that means that when you're from a pod flooding the internet with a whole bunch of packets
That means that these are all being translated by your kernel between the pods IP space and the instances IP space
And then at another level if you're using something like AWS
There's another one for AWS translating between your private IP space and the public IP address of the internet
And each one of those is its own bottleneck
And you'll often see and you probably hear this very often
If you try to mass scan suddenly your connections start dropping
Everything just disappears
Yes
And it's like it's super unreliable what's going on
It's because of this
So what do you do?
You move container networking from a pod to privileged networking
Bad for security good for performance
Sure
Right
So you get rid of one layer of this
Then the second part is you move your instance away from any sort of
Natting from like private IP ranges to public
You just slam it directly onto the public internet
Okay
Right
And then that means that there's no sort of bottlenecks between you and the internet
Unless you've got like an ISP level CG NAT
Sure
Which is where your ISP itself does more natting
So maybe you ask them can I disable CG NAT or opt out or find a different ISP
It's absolutely like one of the reasons why I so value these conversations with you is like
Do you know how long it would take you to get to that level where you understand each one of those steps
About you know the contract table and and the kernel optimizations and then all this various level of natting
And like it's because you have been at war with these problems for the past five years
Oh yeah
Yeah
And man it's just such a pleasure to be able to to sit down and and skip all of that
Um, and so yeah, that's great
So you solve that by by putting it on you know outside of the kubernetes cluster putting it directly on onto a box
That's on the internet as little nat as possible as little bottlenecks as possible
And then you can do more efficient scanning that way and then publish it back into the the message broker or you know
I guess that well, this is another question. This is a little bit of a
I don't know
We won't go too far down this rabbit hole
But what the problem that I had with my with my message broker structure was
I am I had a I had a a queue that was right
Reflect this data to the database. Yeah, right
And that one always had a bottleneck. Yeah, and all you know
All these things would be throwing it into that queue
And that queue would be trying to update the database like 50 bajillion times a second
And I those those messages would always get kind of stuck there and then it would everything would fall apart
So you sort of realized that
I storing a data persistent is a whole different set of problems
That's why dbas and databases administrators was like its own role for all of these decades
And it still is because it's a very relevant position
Yeah, what you find in that situation is now you're in the role of like database optimization
Not in program optimization. Well, I was also using mongodb rather than anything like you know
To be fair is quite performant. Yes, mongodb is web scale. Yeah
Oh my god, dude, I forgot about that
Oh
Yeah
We're gonna link that that's great
Like mongodb is great
But you also have to understand your access patterns and your data patterns, right? Right like
I'm sorry
I'm sorry continue continue
So yeah, you need to understand your access like your both your read and write patterns
And I'm assuming in your case you probably structures like oh
I have an IP address that is sort of what the key is and then I have all the metadata is like blah is the object
Literally yes
And it's kind of good in the sense that it's very simple and it's great for your querying
But it's probably not the best for writing because you're doing a whole bunch of updates to the same keys
Yeah, exactly
Right and you find that
Not all databases handle that really well
And also depending on where your database is hosted and how it's being managed that's its own set of problems, right?
You'll find with databases. You're never really bound by networking. You're very much bound by disk read speed memory bandwidth
How big your caches are that kind of stuff. Yeah
And so
And the size of the DB itself
And the size of its DB
Yeah, and and and so I guess I went with mongo in that scenario
But I see most of the people are going with post postgres
And and so you know, what do you think about that architectural decision? What other you know?
What was the reasoning behind it?
What about no SQL databases versus SQL database when it comes to like and I think the model itself of of just sort of recon data in general
Lends itself a little bit better to a highly relational
You know database and and you know where you can draw map easily draw maps between all of these different objects and have them broken out rather than in
Like a single JSON blob or something like that
Um, so that's kind of where I went wrong with that, but I think like there's not necessarily a right answer
I know some people want like graph databases as well
Yeah, yeah, that's a big that's big. Yeah, so I mean for us
We went for the simple stupid option. We picked postgres for our architecture
Right. There's some other reasons for that mainly around
How it's being used because a lot of the value customers have is like well, we want to query for data with these properties
We want it to be in this part of infrastructure tagged with this that are online that have this port that have this kind of title
And all of these relational elements is sort of how we built out our schema
And this is also where no sequel sucks. It sucks so hard like it's really really bad at that
Like what's nice like iterating over every single document is like oh, yeah, does this match? Does this match? Does this match? Does this match?
Does it match?
So yeah postgres is great for that con asking those kinds of questions. I think dude, I found out about indexes
changed my life
Index like and then I started putting an index on everything and then it
Yeah, I'm sure that went really well
I was like let me just index all the things I think that'll solve my problem
I've spent countless hours just staring at postgres explains trying to understand why queries are slow
Yeah, you have multiple phases of optimizing postgres like the first phase like okay chuck an index on it
Then the next phase is like okay, do I look at start looking at read replicas or do I start looking at like better hardware?
Right, right
And then it's like okay, maybe I go with better hardware
But now you start having the problems like okay
How do I get around the problem that even with indexes these queries are taking a long time?
Right, so what do you do then? Well, maybe I start pre-computing data, right?
Maybe I start using things like materialized views, right?
Those start solving problems, but then it also creates its own problems, right?
Because refreshing materialized views has to happen frequent enough so you have recent data
But then they also consume its own database operations
So I mean at the end of the day engineering is just a whole bunch of trade-offs, right?
It's like I have this much time and this much effort and I have this solution I want to get to
How much time and effort can I spend to get to the best solution?
Yeah, no, that's really well put in it and you know
You're never gonna have a fully optimized solution with no trade-offs in that situation
Yeah, I mean it's back to that 80-20, right?
It's like you start at 80-20 and then maybe 90-10 is where you draw the line because that last 10%
for the extra 50% is just for a non-enterprise use case it's just not worth it
Like it really isn't
Yeah, like it's you versus Sean and like
Yeah, exactly right?
Just take the L like 50% of the time
I did, thank you, thank you very much
And just move on
That's exactly what I did
Yeah, I'm not just going to energy right and I'll just stay there with my takeovers and my day job
That's my
That was the strategy man
That was the strategy
Oh man
Coming back to your question in terms of database architecture
Postgres is great
I think you do need to think a little bit about what your schema looks like
One pitfall I didn't realize until very late on is
Postgres does really poorly when you can like repeatedly update the same rows in very very quick succession
And I think one of the things I would like to have done going back is spent a bit more time thinking about
Like append only or write only tables and like partitioning those out
Interesting, okay
Because you sort of find that if you for example in a very common parent
I was like I have all these IP addresses
I'll just have a column that says whether they're online or offline
And then maybe I'll add a timestamp of when that happens
Right
Yeah
Say you run a mass scan every hour right across all of these IP addresses
You're effectively rewriting this entire table every hour
Right
And it's like even if you don't update the true or false for whether it's online or offline
If you update the timestamp and say I last updated this at this time
You just specialise one
Then
Like the way Postgres works is that when you write a row
Unless you have what they call hot tuples which is some extra space to do small writes
It effectively deletes your row and inserts a new one
Right
Really?
Yes
So that's how Postgres maintains its asset properties
Of like when I write something and I haven't finished yet
You don't read partially what I've written
Right
You have the correct view of the world
Okay
Right
So repeatedly updating the same thing
Will just mean that you're deleting the same row and adding it a whole bunch of times
The way they solve this is what they call vacuuming
Which is they clean up rows that have been deleted
Right
Sure
So you can write to them again
But unless you sort of give it time to do that
If you're writing more than your vacuum is keeping up with
And there's a whole bunch of vacuum tuning stuff that they ask you to do
Then you're just going to quickly grow out in space
Or your index is going to become something very inefficient
Because your table is like what they call bloated
It's like every gigabyte of space might only be 100 megabytes actually occupied
Sure
Yeah
Postgres is great
That being said
Depending on what scale
Like if you're at a small scale and your database is a couple gigabytes
No one cares
Right
But when you're operating like hundreds of gigabyte terabytes of data
Then you have very different questions to answer
Yeah
No for sure
And do you also find benefit
Like with a write only table or a pen only table
With having almost like a version history essentially
Yes
Like what's going on over time
Like what's changed over time
That being said
It also does grow very very quickly
Right
So maybe you might look at some solutions like ClickHouse or what they call
Column
I can't pronounce it
But column based database stores
Right
And they compress data slightly differently
They're better for things like that
Which is kind of like
I draw the analogy to IoT
Because you're kind of doing
The IT use case is that you use things like ClickHouse to measure temperatures across the world
Right
And every second you're recording a new temperature and they add it to this database
And they're very efficient at storing that
I think it's very similar to that because instead of storing temperature
We're storing all things online
Right
Or what's the status code of this
Sure
Right
Across millions of things across the world every hour
So sometimes that might be a better use case
But it sort of comes with the trade-offs like well how do I want to query this
Yeah
Am I just interested in what is the latest result?
Or am I interested in trends?
Or am I interested in slicing up my data depending on which customer is asking?
Yeah
Well and that's why we kind of ask because in the beginning it might be
Oh I really want to just like query this from my command line
But also at some day you might want to look at trends you know
Okay how often are they you know rotating these things IP addresses?
How often are they you know
Or from a customer's perspective like when did this exactly change or
Why are we noticing this strange behavior?
Like is it flipping on and off?
And we get that question so so many times
Yeah
So yeah I think like for bug bounty people I think it's a very different question set
And I think what you should be optimizing for is not like this long-term trend use case
It's what information do I need right now and how do I get there?
Right and only once you've done that then can you start iterating on what schema works for your use case?
Sure
I can't tell you what schema is good because you don't have five engineers behind you building this entire system
Yeah, and and you're not an enterprise application
Yes
And yeah, so so I guess let's let's think about the use case is very simple
What for example one of the things that I I I and we were talking about earlier today with Uriota was
You know dividing out your domains in your IP addresses logically and and not making your your subdomain your primary key
Yeah
Like that was my when I that was my biggest architectural mistake I made when I built my recon system was I was like I was obsessed with subdomains
I was like subdomain is is the end all be all but really at the end of the day it all goes down to I you know IP addresses
I shouldn't say that but it mostly all goes down by
Well, I mean that's a good point
Yeah
I think
So this is the kind of discussion I want to have is like, you know
What what are those those mistakes like focusing on subdomains instead of focusing IP addresses as the lowest level of logical entities
And you know mapping those because yeah, I think it also comes to like what carbon of recon are you doing?
Yeah
And I think subdomains is fine because a lot of things like subdomains is the easiest identifier
Way of looking at something. Yeah
The reason you say IP addresses is relevant is because there's a whole bunch of assets and like
Well, we yeah, what we consider assets that might not have a subdomain associated, right?
Right like companies like
Or just a subdomain that you don't know
Yeah
They don't like they exist on the internet
You just can't see them yet
Yeah, there's also like a whole separate set of pitfalls
Like when you start to go to that level because
IPs rotate like things subdomains get reassigned
So like you might have an IP address that's stored and then you scan you're like, oh my god, there's a new service on this
Yeah, it's exploitable and then it turns out it belongs to somebody else
Like it's come it's not even theirs and then you report it to the company and they're like, you know
We don't we don't know this IP
Yeah, yeah, that's true. I mean, yeah, I think it all it all depends on and this is kind of what we were talking about earlier
Sort of correlation factors and I think that could definitely be
A new logical entity in a recon structure system, you know, like like you have this this domain and you've got that, you know database
What you know about that domain and you've got this subdomain meaning and or fqdn and then you've got this IP address
And then you've got some sort of relationship between the two of them and how that's correlated. It could be a dns
An entry that correlates them. It could be a tls, you know, sni, you know, it could be, you know, historical data
It could be, you know, what else could it be? I'm trying to
What do you think about that?
I've been modeling over this idea for a couple years
Yeah, tried to implement this at AstroNode, but the use case is very nuanced, right?
Yeah, yeah
When you start getting into more and more cloud native apps, the ways you identify what you consider like an asset
Starts to change very differently. Yeah, right in a very traditional old school setting will probably be like
We have IP addresses on servers and that's it. We might give them a subdomain
But when you get to like the other end of the spectrum
Uber starts routing things based on your sub path
And if you want to be more specific, yeah
Uber starts routing things based on your sub path in a specific geolocation. Yeah, right
So even if you hit the same IP address with the same sub domain same sni same path
You'll be hitting two different data centers that might be running different versions of your app. Yeah, right
That's true even further
It might be getting feature flagged and routed to another version of the app based on your user id
Right and all of these means that at the end of the day the app you're looking at might not even be the same one
You might be getting like a china version of the uber app versus a america version of the uber app
Or even you might be getting a beta uber app versus the production app
Right, and I think factoring all of these in into like what you call this correlation. Yeah, probably is overkill for most people
Yeah, but I want it to be perfect
Well, how about this every single company you create a unique correlation, right?
You build your mental model you grab cosmen back and you ask him how does
employ their apps right and then you work backwards from there you say I factor it
It doesn't care about geo location. They don't care about user id. They care about their tenant id. They care about this subdomain
Whatever, but for uber
Totally different story now. We're an entire different paradigm. He's a new correlation method, right? You want to go to the nth degree?
You might as well
No, I mean you made a perfect point which is that we can't
Over I mean you so perfectly pointed out that that flaw of like this is just going to be way over engineering
Some of these some of these things and and at the end of the day you are gonna
You are gonna you know run into these these scenarios where you're like, ah, it's not perfect
But then you gotta you gotta decide is the trade-off of that fixing that problem actually gonna get me enough bounties
To justify the time that I'm spending on and the answer to that a lot of the time is no
I mean something unless you want to make it your thing. Yeah, like sometimes that's what we're hacking around it
Right, you might have the system that works for 90% of the cases and then you decide
Okay
I'm gonna spend like three weeks looking at Google infrastructure, right?
And now this is its entire own base that has its own books written on it, right?
So I'm just gonna hack together something that's just for this and maybe you'll find that I've now spent three months on it
I understand it enough now
I can merge it back into mainline and feed this across the rest of it
Yeah, you don't have to make everything into your giant monolithic
Beast, right? You can always have smaller pieces that's for something else
And then once you sort of figure out how this works it then comes back naturally into the rest of the work you're doing. Yeah
Wow
Yeah, it's it's a you know, I like you said I have retreated from my my recon world into my live hacking event world
And I've just been spending so much time in the in the you know hands on the keyboard manual hacking lately
That I forgot about all the horrendous challenges that there are in the in the
So it really is an engineering
It's a it's an engineering problem. It's an engineering problem space like you have to realize that like if you're trying to tackle this problem
Individually and you're running into struggles and you're not an engineer well
That that's to be expected. Yeah
Yeah
Like it's pretty hard like literally there are full-time engineers who spend all day every day trying to solve this problem
Yeah, there are teams of it. Yeah, teams and yeah multiple teams of engineers who spend all day trying to fix this problem and
Can't or have to spend weeks
years solving it, right? And so like I think
Again, like
Optimize what you need to optimize for it, right? Like think about your problem set think about the context think about
What data do you need for what targets you're focusing on?
And if you have to make an optimization make an optimization if you don't just don't do it
You know what I mean? Like get it where you need it to be and then use it to its fullest
And if it's not enough then improve yeah, or hire a company of people and do it though, right? Yeah, yeah
Just become acid note
It's easy yeah, so so I guess one of the things that I wanted to bring up as well
Just kind of in pursuit of the relentless return to deep technical content
um
Can you give us some wisdom on how to deal with dns wild cards?
Yeah, and what kind of pitfalls we can
Avoid in that area and for those of you that are not super familiar with the concept while I let sean think for a second
um
The concept is that some wild card
Sub some domains
Facebook good example
Facebook um zoom also has it
Slack
Yeah, there's a lot of wild cards and essentially what that means is you can put any random string at you know
What is it zoom dot us or something like that slack comm and it will resolve to an ip address?
Yes, yeah
It's basically anything that lets you generate subdomains like shopify store dot my shopify.com or whatever like
The way that all of those route without them creating new dns entries is that they have one catch-all dns entry
That's right. It's wild card
And so basically anything dot whatever resolves to like the same set of ip addresses or the same c names and then that gets routed
And so the big the biggest problem with that is figuring out okay
Which one of these is a wild card response?
Which is always going to be the same and has no interesting data or which one of these is unique
And that's one of the hardest problems
Well, I mean the way we solve it at work is very different from how we solve it in bounties
Yeah
When we solve it at work, we have access to your aws account
So we don't need to guess
So we can save a whole bunch of
Energy
Beautiful love that for you
In bounty
Let me just ask for the
Exactly
Can you just give us your dns
But in the bug bounty space we we do it at resolve time like we build our own custom resolver that does all the
Like resolution checking and it pretty much like does wild card detection every layer
Right, so at every depth of this update and we start trying to detect is this a wild card or not
We figure out like what what is what is expected to be a wild card what isn't a wild card
And then it kind of depends on what you're optimizing for at that point
Are you willing to resolve millions of attempts to find that one or two records that is true or not?
Or do you just discard this entire set and move on to the next set?
Which once again, those are both viable options
I've done both of those before and they both result in great things
One because you you're you know if you do actually go through the weeds
It results in you finding hosts that no one else finds because they're not willing to dig through the weeds
But if you if you don't and you ignore that whole thing you save hours and hours and hours of time that you would
Solving one of the hardest problems that you run into
Because at face value, it's like the simplest way is ignore it or look through every single one
It's like neither of those options are super great one super tedious and the other leaves a gap
It's only tedious when it's slow
But if you hypothetically could resolve millions of results a second
Hypothetically of course right then if only there was a company that did that yeah, right?
That's exactly right
You you don't need to like have the trade-off right just resolve millions of results a second
Yeah, so that goes back to the optimization problem too and and and I want to say I haven't looked at this code in a really long time
But I want to say when I when I tried to solve this problem and actually tried to be able to weed out all the wild cards
I actually
Resolved the I resolved a certain subdomain and then I I appended something to it and can and
Resolved it a couple times as well and compared the result and so for every single entry that I was doing
I was resolving
You know three or four times so it was it was growing, you know linearly in that in that capacity, right?
And and it was and it was also
There there was that and then there was another piece of it um and you
This yeah
Because and you can cash it a little bit with saying okay
I've already sort of figured out whether this level of the subdomain is a is a wild card or not
But then you run into scenarios where you've got like
um subdomain dash
Everything wild card, right?
And then you're always it's gonna blow up your database again if you if you do it so
The answer to everything in computer science is the hash map
Hash map everything
Yeah, just hash map all the wild cards for every single level
Yeah
And then now you can just start matching it every corresponding level and see how far you get that's well
Yeah, what a beautiful structure at the hash map
It's lovely man. Yeah, no, no that that is good advice though, you know, so you're saying, you know, let's just take uber for example
uber.com test that uber.com
Okay, I've determined test that uber.com is not a a you know, and then you know, you've got
abc.uber.com
Okay, that's that is a wild card
And then you can continue to grow as the subdomains change and you at some point you will have already resolve that or you can quickly resolve that and you're good to go
Yeah, yeah, okay
We are getting the signal from our manager right now that it's time to wrap up this episode
Yes, Sean dude. Thanks for coming on man. Thank you for letting us pick your brain
We will we will definitely have Sean on again
Um, not like this though. We're gonna have to do it over zoom because yeah, I mean
I just like to fly me to the states
We'll just fly you out with all of our crazy critical thinking budget
Um, you got anything you wanna you want to shill to the people?
Yeah, don't try to solve hard problems if you don't have to
Yeah, and don't try to find hard bugs where you can find easy ones. Yeah, and where can they find us?
Yeah, you can find acid note
At acid is dot com.
acid note dot com, acid note dot io
You can find us on twitter
I think like at acid note probably
And then you can find me at
Twitter at like at Sean Yo, I think
Is it Sean Yo? Do we need to like check that really quick or are you feeling pretty confident about that?
I'm not confident. Okay.
I only shitpost on twitter. There's nothing used to that
We'll put it down below. Don't worry.
Actually on your own. Okay. Okay. There we go. All right. That's a wrap. Awesome. That's a wrap.
Peace